l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vigente oggi siano sul
nuaches con creazioni facciamo premessa
velocissima prima di cominciare allora
mi di gioco horror abbastanza famoso si
impersona questo bambino che dovrebbe
essere l'anticristo per molti
l'anticristo germano mosconi per molti è
questo bambino che faccia i poteri
brutti il primo lucius e uscito nel 2012
e io l'avevo già giocato nel 2002 quando
era uscito quindi lo so già per questo
non l'ho mai fatto e per questo fu
giusta premessa semplicemente per
rispondere a domande ma farina perché un
file 1 prima poi fa il fratello già
fatto quindi so cosa succede quindi non
ha senso voglio possiamo cominciare
sì che ho saltato tutorial perché sono
ci mettevamo anni per quello
siamo partiti che bella fate a ok ok me
la spieghi in breve primi hanno portato
che fico niente siamo partiti così bello
comunque lucio 2 grazie a una roba che
figo
sono partito così fantastico ci siamo
ragazzi allora deve uscire bello ma
riportanti incazzato dobbiamo uscire
questo allora tentato di farmi
l'elettroshock è finito leggermente ma
le ascolta zio fatto la stessa fine del
mio prof di informatica devo riuscire a
trovare il modo di uscire allora è un
cibo un po ingegnoso quindi io non
faccio un po schifo ma posso usare lo
posso fare a lui lele procedere cazzo ci
sono partite le chiavi perfetto scalda
giuro che non volevo però posso prendere
le chiavi grazie gentile le uso comunque
ragazzi a parte il vestito un po
scassato sono tranquillo posso aprire
porti in giro sta guardando i miei video
là dentro i dall ansia sta cosa
sciamanico prima che mi girano le palle
cazzo
devo riuscire a far girare il sud
efficiente si può
ok ho già capo ragazzi ho già capito
tutto perfetto lo faccio vedere io
lampadario tanto sono fenomeni se cosa
defibrillatore cosa faccio
le tv shock sa bene cioè no ma scusami
se io vado di che si è morto se già
fatto che perché andava veramente volete
ma io l'ho ucciderlo quella palla no
mica mi sono rovinato l'infanzia vabbè
non importa prendo le chiazze e delle
chiavi io volevo rompere la pa da
comunque ragazza non importa avremo
avremo altre occasioni migliori non vi
preoccupate voi abbiate capito che meno
come sto gioco cioè devo uccidere le
persone in modo in modo bello e ga
ragazzi mi sta bene
no non mi supera sta seguendo un
carrello prontamente vuole violentarmi
ok
[Musica]
vorrei capire
no basta ma fatemi capire o mio dio
ragazzi c'è una donna nuda che corre
ascoltami non è una donna giorno scolti
zio è mica garisti ti va di fare cosa
fai
no no no non si è non si può fare questa
cosa costa zione di b ma non ce l'hanno
liberato dei deficienti e devo prendere
per alimenti alle chiavi di quei
deficienti o con le prendo le chiavi
devo bruciarli brucia comunicazione
brucio infatti capire come cazzo faccio
regali
all 8 è che cosa me ne faccio le cose 8
a meno che io non lanci delle cose là
dentro cosa cazzo ci lancio so se
scatolette di thor ragazzi di schelin
ancione scatolette di tonno e li uccido
perfetto scatoletta di tonno fa il suo
dovere perche e andata si è andata
perfino fatto jesus christ da una
scatola di tonno che è successo
bicicletta si è bruciato una scatoletta
ritorno usato ragazzi io io e scatolette
di tonno possiamo fare di meglio è la
madonna io mangiano più torna in vita
mia mi hai fatto hai fatto il tuo dovere
comunque ho bruciato due persone volta
fratello ti puoi farmi seguono le chiama
grazie perfetto le chiavi cielo sa cos'è
questa roba devo praticamente sparare il
carrello contro uno dei piceni contro
quei [ __ ] gli devo lanciare il
carrello addosso ma serio data fratello
agli oggi prove spara come cazzo faccia
qualcosa per dal fuoco qualsiasi cosa
del tonno non so il tonno funziona
sempre
merda l'ho mancato vai col tonno
[ __ ] forza tonno si ritorno il
tonno è la risposta tutto ragazzi
vai con cioè a chi è bello che sei di
una donna dietista concretezza ma bene
ce lo fa non fate domande non so come ma
buongiorno sacco come cazzo hai fatta
finire così giuro che non vorrei
sdrammatizzare niente però mi fa troppo
ridere questa cosa
devo fare qui ho trovato la madonna solo
goku devo entrare qua dentro tanto che
questo mi chiamano ciak di ennis dot.com
in che chi questo caso posso parlare con
te rivela quindi vento cocco ogni volta
che la ricarica veloce ma è logico cazzo
che questo chi cazzo è questo via via
via via via chiude maledizione come la
frutta il mio inizio
no non posso aprire la porta li mortacci
tua come faccio a uccidere sto
deficiente ma quanta gente ci di che
cazzo fai quello
[Musica]
il fratello mio sei un figo chi lo
faccio tipo entrare qua dentro con
defibrillatore ma lo schiaccia di brutto
no ma come ha fatto a vedermi
no non lo verde come va sì ho vinto mi
fa piacere che anche la morto riesce ad
attrezzare il bastone amico mio mi manca
solo il vestito che credo che sia qui se
lo trovate ecco qua il figo della
madonna cielo fatto ragazzi devo
lasciare il piano posso andarmene grazie
ok ci ho messo agli anni vorrei stato
bello matri vedere se si andrà è
bellissimo ragazzo ricordava così feed
breve ma intenso ragazzi praticamente se
non ne lascia insomma non è che bello
sto ascensore ci mette una tranquillità
che na roba incredibile mi conosce dei
capelli peggio di me la potevo stare
chiuso tutto il giorno dopo ancora
cliccare il tasto famoso grazie gentile
va bene è parte ste cagate giorno mi
scusino secondo le dispiace se posso
non volevo non volevo dire si fa niente
della porta faccia finta di niente e
stia zitto è perché sono poi son cazzi
miei da ucciso una persona però non
vuole stavolta non volevo veramente ci
sono in buona fede ragazzi mi sto
trascinando cannes ce la fai snow si è
incastrato li mortacci io ho ucciso però
ne che ma devi incastrati con la smetti
di fa vedere il pene leghe model
incastro di quel momento ne costa porta
niente se incastrato il braccio regalo
lascio quasi mancherebbe altro che poi
io posso togliere gli ispiratori a tutti
ah sì che fosse che bello ragazzi fate
uccidere delle persone se promosso
grazie che è divertente
devo uccidere delle persone ragazzi non
so bene chi però devo uccidere del paese
sta fissando mentre finisce a veloce no
non si è tolto euro che sono diecimila 3
stai fermo tornei di zio che cosa fa no
non ti abbassare stai fermo niente merda
su una mira di merda bravo a posto ci ha
pensato lui stesso va bene io non so se
veramente sono più letali o gli
defibrillatori oppure il tonno una delle
due è importante che riesca ad a da a
fuggire di qua ed inter core dentro
capitoli ok ho capito quindi devo
entrare dal condotto dell'aria familiare
intorno fa mise il turn è la risposta
sempre far usare perfetto e ora come
cazzo lo apro tt in giro dentro torno a
casa
ok ok per facevo fatta non so cosa ho
fatto ma di sicuro si aprirà alla porta
si è aperta
oddio giorno anche a te che figo che chi
è che mi ha aperto la porta la
scatoletta non so io non capisco se già
un ragazzo della pazienza però ma chi è
[Musica]
oh cazzo
salve è una delle cose più macabre che
abbia mai vincesse disegnato le ali e
poi si è ucciso devo fare luce su questa
faccenda ho capito però il problema è
che è un caso madonna ed che schifo io
seguo la fra ormai se non ci fosse la
freccia sarei morto praticamente
perfetto salve dentro nota zio mi
servono le chiavi mimì passi le chiavi
grazie come faccio a uccidere sto
[ __ ] nota zio mi vedi che sto
facendo a lei che il giocoliere adesso
seguimi segue no cazzo lo manca dona che
mira di merda che ciò devo prenderlo
così non ce l'ho fatta
invece ce l'ho fatta perché sono tutti
gli [ __ ] nel cervello di cerchi
mi fa napoli incredibile va bene importa
apre al padre maronno scotto cosa ci fa
a non è una sorella sorella è pronta per
una defibrillato come si deve la fai il
bravo e la madonna che dance
[Musica]
l'unica cosa che mi vien in mente per
uccidere st [ __ ] l'unica proprio e
lanciarli delle cose avvelenate ma
proprio l'unica ascoltati ha mangiate
per favore rava mangia le cose da terra
brava così mangia porca [ __ ] che sono
buone se la prese se c'è la famiglia
mezz'ora per passare non sapevo come
ucciderla impossibile questa mandata
veramente di culo che il giorno e non
sono stato io non sono stato io mi sta
seguendo il corpo lo sono stata io a via
via via lunigiana sui vecchi di micro
porto [ __ ] trango sospetti affanculo
smettila di seguirmi [ __ ] ti chiudo
dentro e non sono stato io ascoltami
scherza guarda io no sto scherzando sto
scherzando verde via via via via via via
perché non solo perché delle chiavi in
mano cazzo e perché una tipa è morta la
versioen dettagli bene devo solo andare
non ce la posso più fare senza finito
per oggi la dose di uccisioni gratuite
perfetta per ragazzi con cui ho poi
episodio fatemi sapere se vi piace se
volete che lo continui continuerò nel
prossimo episodio se volete fatemi
sapere dove cazzo sono bellissimi
capelli sono belli usi garnier questi
ragazzi conclude l'episodio cosa sento
se video è piaciuta stato commento mi
piace è incapace di facebook e come non
divido tra tale descrizione cioè se
volessi di skype è uno stupido delle
ragazze
[Musica]